I can't believe it
the bakery section is flying Anthony and
David have got 11 huge pies ready Dave
is fairly young standing up currently
spent like a pig doing so it's like a
like a kitchen of misfits however
they're not givin up legs I know - [ __ ]
calling it and you know what this might
be the turning point where I'll never
come at division again I've become a
good father becoming [ __ ] big ass
people love me so instead of their name
[ __ ] them half an hour to go and my
main courses are almost done okay steam
rolling oil pokéheroes work as a team
guys but Tesla and his team still have
40 trays of potatoes to roast yeah the
final orders are in from the wings and
Lawrence's hard work has paid off his
chili is ready
as it comes out when they gonna pick it
up
Sallah minutes the boys are pulling out
all the stops this has been a massive
task and I think I may have a team at
last the usual now is gonna give the
call concentrate don't start showing you
over each other
well it's potatoes one rack need to be
calling cheering for the tea in a minute
chili con carne I'm coming coming some
good 800 people I'm off to G wing to
find out what our customers think I look
better the last time yeah I can see
onions on top last time it was just
black color already on onion gravy yeah
you can see the difference wait for the
phone yeah yeah
nice I answered in thing we're gonna
make that this boy we said them a task I
didn't think this possible to pull it
off
and I was slightly concerned that
they're going to shy away from six seven
eight hour day I've been on their feet
turns and it's been a long one but it's
gone it's gone well